veamos si podemos calcular el volumen de
esta figura de acá nos han dado algunas
de las dimensiones de esta este lado
mide 2 centímetros este lado de aquí
mide 7 centímetros este mide 12
centímetros este 5 centímetros y este de
aquí arriba 3 centímetros como siempre
los invito a que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolver esto por su cuenta
hay muchas maneras de resolverlo la
forma en la que a mí me gusta resolverlo
es descomponiéndolo en dos prismas
rectangulares y hay varias formas de
descomponer esto en prismas
rectangulares el que a mí se me ocurre
es por ejemplo tener un prisma así que
tiene tres centímetros de ancho cinco
centímetros de alto
y tiene 7 centímetros de profundidad y
si esto fuera transparente veríamos que
continúa así
así que este tiene tres centímetros de
ancho
siete centímetros de largo mide lo mismo
que esta parte de aquí el ancho por la
longitud por la altura que es de 5
centímetros nos da veamos 3 por 7 nos da
21 21 por 5 nos va a dar 20 por 5 es 100
más 1 por 55 105 centímetros cúbicos así
que este prisma rectangular azul de acá
tiene un volumen de 105 centímetros
cúbicos y ahora vamos a calcular por
separado el volumen de este prisma
rectangular que estoy resaltando en rosa
si esto fuera transparente lo veríamos
así
así que cuáles son las dimensiones de
este sabemos que su altura es de 2
centímetros y sabemos que es su
profundidad esta de acá es de 7
centímetros pero cuánto mide esto de
aquí que podemos considerar su longitud
y anchura dependiendo de como queramos
llamarlo bueno todo esto de acá me de 12
centímetros de aquí acá y sabemos que de
aquí a acá mide 3 centímetros así que
esta parte que sobra de verdad me 19
centímetros
esta distancia de acá el volumen de este
prima rectangular rosa es de 9
centímetros por 7 centímetros
por la altura que es 2 centímetros lo
que nos va a dar 9 por 7 es 63 63 por 2
es igual a 60 por 2 120 3 por 2 es igual
a 6 por lo que nos da 126 centímetros
cúbicos y el volumen total de todo esto
va a ser el volumen del prisma
rectangular rosa que es de 126
centímetros cúbicos más el volumen del
prisma azul que es de 105 centímetros
cúbicos esto nos va a dar 65 11 dejamos
aquí una unidad y la decena que nos
sobra las ponemos aquí así que una
decena más dos decenas son tres decenas
una centena más otra centena es igual a
dos centenas por lo que tenemos 231
centímetros cúbicos como el volumen
total de esta figura